musica e video giampiero
[Musica]
due gemelli va bene osar me c'è gente
qua te do fare ciò picchiarlo
mi prendo il naso non c'era un altro
amici cosa devo fare qua ad appiccare in
pugno cioè prendo qualcosa si tira un
pugno quali marketing at aiutato ciao
amico aspetto devo prendere le cose che
devo fare
gianpi ma stai scherzando
ma fra è bellissimo posso far fare
alcuno la gente quando si è messo
fantastico è sempre stata mia ma posso
anche schivare a chi ha detto che fa
vige un cancro sono morto è questo il
campo
come capire attimo cosa posso fare ciao
zio vieni qua allora ti giuro non ho mai
giocato a roma purifica affilate
gianfrate allora mi dicono che siamo
super 8 credo che tu concordi allora la
cosa che non capisco è la distanza tra
me e il muro quindi ho un po di kagari
beccare il muro ci sono io che sei tu
se sì allora ho paura di perdere le mani
quindi vi devo attrezzare la più o
meglio ci siete
ma come mi si è scassato il telefono
gianpi ma questo c'è una pistola cosa
faccio io aiuto a e che sanno fare qua
funghi sonica e no non ci arrivo è
troppo lontana spetta preso la pistola
gianfrate no vabbè non possa aver fatto
sul serio sta cosa
ok forse questo non lo devo fare è
fighissimo te lo giuro non ho mai
giocato a roma così fino in vita mia
ciao nuovi il corpo a dame to così ta
aiuto da una pistola da me to pistola
ora mi sento james bond però vorrei
sparare anche alla gente di luxury che
vorrei sparare alla gente da lontano
possibilmente shadow shuriken con a
picchiarlo si è la piana la che shuriken
esclusa come l'angelo jolie che se
faccio le cipolle questi ciao a fare
così sono bravissimo il problema è che
non posso lanciarlo però è veramente
filo va bene oggi vi insegno come
difendervi
nel caso di attaccassero condiviso lì
che arriva il tipo partita
chi ha visto che il bravissimo il
problema è che non so come si lanciano
però dettagli pistola sono in una
situazione di kakà giampiero però fa
niente è buona grazie pazza ma ho
beccato qualcuno mi sento tipo i monti
ok ma non funzionare calcio la magari
anche tu io tocco la faccia la gente la
gente esplode nel senso che uscirò fai
una prova
fai una giravolta sono da un'altra volta
che dopo la bici ma che poi madonna mi
sono visto il bruttissimo quando ti
sparano infatti non a gianpi ti auguro
di non provare mai un proiettile in
faccia e orribile buona grazie
no acer a1 dietro ecco perché ma come si
lanciano gli oggetti porca è bellissimo
te lo giuro cioè non so se sei niente
morto parco demonio o cosa peccato
e allora aiuto che non corre non si
chiama me di pietro ci ha aiutati
vorrei evitare di tirare pugni per
questo motivo problemi mettete avanti ne
seguirà la mia voce non seguì la mia
voce
mi spiace livello di rischio tanto
temuta camera di marco ok quanto ancora
dura sta roba
p chiesto cosa cenere mannaia con le
armi ah no dello schivo armi un casino
no grazie a casa mia sembra un po un
deficiente mondo vite così tantissimi
grazie picchia testa bottiglia da ucciso
sono fortissimo
mamma mia che gioco strambo teacher lo
sono tutti i giochi che ho fatto questo
non è i più strani sono in sudato come
lo schifo obiettivo più avanti però
normale mira alla testa
vediamo che succede esperti
a guardare a me oddio che è successo
alla mia mano
cos'è sta roba è non so se è normale
però vabbè super8 disco b va bene
aiutami perché non ho mai usato pc così
vecchi cosa solo fa dove lo metto il
disco gli scopi al resto va agli scopi
fammi sentire delle canzoni belle tipo
martin galli scrisse put on your hands
ed è questo che cos'è prince ma questo è
di mortacci d'uso è la cosa ne capisco
io di questo gioco
io capisco sono queste ecco anche noi lo
ha capito che ha visto amici spiegatevi
qual è il vostro problema lo risolvo io
bella ciao ho preso un proiettile sul
naso mi ha fatto male non so se ti
interessa però mi ha fatto malissimo
aiuta non avremo un picco al figlio
rilanciato non si faccia vabbè giusto
ciao grazie calcolatrice e matematica
che hanno fatto sempre tutti no però no
però non è capito meglio uccisi non sta
capendo non ho mai capito come gli
uccisi te lo dico io li ho uccisi in
modo figo la squadra può fare una cosa
molto difficile boschiva di tutti finché
non arriva qua poi prenderlo a pugni in
faccia a maya a posso stoppare i
proiettili con l'arma che fini non ci
credo cosa ho fatto
va bene vai sono stanchissimo però te lo
giuro io aiuta
aiuta
cosa sta succedendo cosa devo fare qua
amici gente che mi crolla addosso
vabbè mi alzo c'è un coltello non
c'erano mai a prenderlo è lo re mi alzo
va bene ho finito che scusatemi porca
paolo ciao maglia che il casinò allora
una bel regalo anni tenente porca vacca
questo come spalla è bravo e io aiuto
nei ricordi di uno dei festival è
impossibile hanno fatto privato di tutti
è possibile ci sono tracce di muffa
gente al nayat nostra non ci sono e non
ci sono sceso l'oro mancato è orribile
non riesco a schivarli tutti aia datemi
qualcosa a lanciare ama ciò le armi ma
guarda lì son riuscito a vincere così
non so come fa dopo spesso non a tirarmi
7 dello see me devo far vedere una cosa
la videocamera quelli ma poi vai un
attimo poi lo guarda lì davanti
spiegaglielo
possiamo spiegarti dopo che abbiamo
registrato
io non lo vedo
rientra è una grafica questo elemento
questo caso però cioè ai molti meno
pelli
dimmi se senti otorini là dentro
si no
però che posizione non lo so non l'ho
ucciso così come ho fatto io
vabbè dovrei aver finito in teoria
aspetta è di me devo aspettarci un
elicottero che mi sta accadendo in
faccia non so sembra una cosa positiva
errore a me io in realtà sono in una
realtà virtuale dentro una realtà
virtuale fighissimo
ci sono nel matrix praticamente poi c'è
questo qua che assomiglia un po a marco
in teoria facciamo l'ultima dire che va
bene va in tribunale matrix
questo si chiama coltello quello si
chiama nemico voler occhio tifo l'aido
ti stavo per uccidersi insieme il nostro
invece grazie grazie per vendicatori
farlo
e stato bellissimo oggi aiuto è meglio
cosa devo fare
sono molto dai ragazzi spero che video
vi sia piaciuto
io sono stato dentro al matrix per 30
minuti più o meno come sono il sacchetto
sulla perfetta
penso che avere marco sia contento di
utilizzo del bike visto sponsorizzando
la maglia non so se ho visto hai visto
sono passato fatto
in realtà io l'ho messa preventivamente
perché sapevo che me l'avrebbe tolto il
buy però vedendo la maglia si è poi
rincuorati superò le riconosce no questo
no ma che è stata di videogiochi ragazzi
soprattutto in questo momento
niente ragazzi spero vi sia piaciuto
ringrazio marco per aver apprezzato la
maglietta al viper la casa e il canale
di youtube
né ci vediamo in questa guida
[Musica]